if you're watching this on your daily
commute you'd be forgiven for feeling
less than enthusiastic about trains but
as hard as it is to imagine before the
advent of commuter rail people faced a
lot more peril than indefinite delays
expensive fares and getting to know the
intimate notes of strangers body odors
the world's first purpose-built
passenger railway opened in 1830 and ran
between Liverpool and Manchester prior
to that if you wanted to travel between
the two you would either have to spend
12 hours meandering along the canals
which wasn't so bad if you were willing
to shut your eyes and pretend you were
in Venice or you could risk a three-hour
bone jolting stagecoach ride down narrow
winding roads and keeping everything
cross that you wouldn't crash the new
trains reached speeds of up to 35 miles
per hour while some thrill-seeking
passengers treated the experience like a
day off some towers all this weren't
terrified by the speed an early
passenger Charles young said in less
than five minutes off we went like a
shot from a gun no sooner did we come to
a field than it was a mile behind us
nobody tell Charles about the Shanghai
maglev which with speeds of up to two
hundred and sixty seven point eight
miles per hour is the fastest train in
the world it's hard to imagine how
impressive this new invention was to
early adopters actress Fanny Kemble
described the romanticism of it you
can't imagine how strange it seemed to
be journeying on thus without any
visible course of progress other than
the magical machine with its flying
white breath and rhythmical and varying
pace you might find it comforting that
one thing that hasn't changed is that
the railway company underestimated the
demand for their magical machine having
budgeted for a daily quota of 250
passengers the railway regularly found
itself carrying more than four times
that many one thing was modern commuters
should perhaps be grateful for although
first-class passengers on the early
trains had covered
everyone else was exposed to the
elements at least now we all get a roof
we can also count ourselves lucky to
have official stops and platforms at
first stops will I request what that
quickly became inconvenient you can
probably guess why
and with no raised platforms passengers
boarded the train at track level
definitely not a risk you take today
while the rail network wasn't and still
isn't perfect it's easy to forget just
how revolutionary it actually was the
easy journey between Manchester and
Liverpool meant people could more
effectively meet Indy business had new
opportunities for leisure and maybe even
to find love knowledge and ideas could
also be communicated more quickly than
ever before with the transportation of
newspapers and Mail as the rail network
grew more accurate timekeeping was
needed to keep travelers on track clocks
around the country were synchronized and
standardized and railway time rules this
ensured that six o'clock in Oxford was
the same as in Crewe and borough so
whether you love or hope rail travel
there's no denying that life in the UK
today would be unimaginable without it
and the next time you've got you nose in
someones armpit think back to a time
when commuter rail was an exciting
magical and even terrifying new
technology you might just see it in a
whole new light
you